[Music]
what do you think of this okay first of
all I know I'm cocaine dealer look right
now but what do you think of this I got
a dog tag with the kids initials on it
you think that's good not good because I
got Jasmine the same one but hers is
silver and it has the kids birthstones
in it but do you think it's a good idea
was this did I did I
not do something right let's start from
the beginning okay uh when did you
conceive the idea it was it your own
idea did you see an ad for someone doing
this did you I saw
in the Jonah Hill movie the one that he
did on Netflix with Eddie Murphy I saw
that he was wearing a dog tag in one of
the one of the uh scenes and I said I
like dog text because I've never fought
in the Army but I like to think I'm in
the army of God I'd like to think I'm
defending the state of New York at all
times and I thought I'm also defending
my family so I said what better things
always at War potentially exactly I'm at
war with my emotions sometimes I'm at
war with my with my gut health right so
I said I am not necessarily a soldier in
the United States Army but I am a
soldier another thing so I I do qualify
to wear a dog Tech where podcast Wars so
I said what about the dog head what the
thing that's not going to change about
me what are what are things that are
always going to mean something to me
um and I said the kids so I said tdv the
kids names yeah and I gave it to Jasmine
and she liked it she really did you're
going to be skipping ahead okay watch
the Eddie Murphy movie with Jonah Hill
yes and then you had the idea and then
you you you thought of the idea of the
dog tags and their initials and you went
to a jewelry store that you go to
normally know that I got my watch from I
went I got you custom-made jewelry I
just remember this oh yeah yeah
let me see yeah the Playboy nameplate
that's amazing yeah I still have it yeah
with the like the spades on and the
thing yeah that's what we wore that's
what all the like the guido kid that's
what the kids wore and when I was
younger over there turtlenecks would
take cavaricis that exact name of it
either had one or you didn't or you
didn't and you did and people wanted I
never got one but I have one but I got
it when you were doing them you gave it
to me in Vegas when you were doing the
um Italian boys
Bay Ridge Boys Backstreet Boys when you
were doing I was honest I was like oh
this is so this is so and I got those
custom-made it took months yeah and I
and I I I think it was probably a
misguided gift right because I I was
more excited about it than I think it
then it ended up being and it took time
and effort I don't know if it was worth
it in the end because I don't think that
I don't know I don't think well the
reason why I don't wear it because it
genuinely doesn't fit around my neck but
I could get more links to make it fit
around because the chain itself right
but I had actually just got you the
charm but I have it I don't know but I
didn't take note of his reward and I
have no idea if you did but even even
Giannis I just don't think you guys wore
them it's a shame but um so so my point
is I had to search out who still made
those custom so you just Googled
something I I walked into it I walked
into the jewelry store good people there
and I and I walked in and I said can you
make this is yeah they said what's the
inspiration I said Jonah Hill in the
Netflix movie with Eddie Murphy and I
had a screenshot of it and if you Google
if you Google Jonah Hill dog tag it pops
up but you I mean it's just a dog take
why'd you take a screenshot of the I
don't know what I was thinking
um you know what's crazy I was cleaning
my house I was cleaning my closet uh I'm
sorry Mom I never meant to hurt you
um and I I actually found my
grandfather's dog tags from the war that
I had in my draw and I helped I held his
dog tag from the United States Army in
World War II correct and I held it in my
hand two days ago only why did you throw
that on
um
I shall I thought about it it's it's
it's it's broken where it connects to
the where like a chain would go through
but I guess I could have it fixed and
it's much smaller than this this is too
big it's not gold actually this one is
like a hard plastic or something right
um right yeah but I just I had thought
thoughts of dog tags just two days ago
because I what I realized is it's doing
it this way number one it's a little big
it am I wearing a license plate number
two the one that I got for Jasmine the
kids birthstones because it goes down
this way same thing but silver same
thing does it look like a stop light
surprised her yeah so on hers it has
three stones with the kit the kids
birthstones to match the TD and the V oh
so you have a t d and a v on hers yes
but with birthstones yes with their
children's birthstone how did you decide
on Silver versus gold at all she's more
silver
um you know it's surprised you surprised
her surprise which isn't nice which is
the way to go because you came home with
something wrapped yes they wrapped it up
for me and this was a just because gift
just because and when when did you give
it to her I gave it to her about a week
ago take me through that moment you came
home I came home are you excited I came
home I was excited I had a little bag I
had a little bag it was late though I
got I got I picked up the gift at about
4 P.M I didn't get home till about 10 30
11 so if the kids were asleep everybody
was asleep okay Jasmine was asleep but I
thought she was she was she thought this
was grounds for a wake up yes so I
didn't necessarily wake her up with my
hands or any physical activity I got a a
toothbrush like a motorized toothbrush
that I brought started brushing my teeth
in the bedroom not in the bathrooms
okay so she started listening is it
motorized
or sonic electric electric
a motorized wheelchair but a toothbrush
all right so she woke up yeah she woke
up and then she woke up and she was like
woke up she goes why are you brushing
your teeth in the bedroom and I was like
oh I didn't mean to wake you up sorry
and she goes yes you did you were
brushing your teeth in the bedroom and I
was like yeah I'm sorry I was like while
you're up though I said and I pulled
this out and I swear to God her first
thing she was like are those the kids
initials I was like yeah she goes it
looks like a license plate
[Laughter]
yeah so I said I said I don't think it
does it's a dog tag and then she goes
why would you get a dark Tech with the
kids initials I swear to God and then I
was like that's terrible and I was like
I was like oh I was like well here's
yours and then she was like here I'm
gonna open this now and I was like yeah
just open it quick and she's like okay
so she opens it and she goes she looked
at and she goes oh this is the same as
yours except mine has the birthstones
and I was like yeah I was like do you do
you like it like be honest I was like I
could take it back and she was like how
could you take it back
oh my God
[Laughter]
how can you take it back it's customized
I go I swear to God I go I go I guess
you're right I can't I can't
[Music]
give my wife
yeah I think you should leave
you go what are you feeling inside I was
literally dying inside because I spent a
good amount of money on this and she
goes and she goes you can't take it back
it's customized and I go oh yeah I
didn't think and she goes it's fine it's
fine
I see you don't want to put it on she
goes I'm just going back to sleep and I
said all right but you'll wear it
tomorrow she goes yeah and then I swear
to God she comes back she comes back
with it on like you know because she
first of all she came down the stairs
the next morning without it on and I I
had it on and by the way when you walk
with this it's sweet it clinks it like
clinks it's very heavy yeah yeah so she
comes so she comes back with it on and
you know she comes back she doesn't have
it on and then she comes back down the
stairs and she hears this clinking and
my middle daughter she goes because you
know like Scrooge you've seen the movie
Scrooge shackles the shackles so my my
daughter goes she hears that she just
hears this coming down the stage you
can't see and she's like this eating
around me she goes Jake get Marley's in
the house
she said yes because she goes Jacob
Marley is the one and then and I said oh
no don't worry and then and then she
goes oh do you like it whatever and then
my my daughter you know like like you
know like looking at it she goes oh she
goes tdv like you know my brother me and
them and whatever and then she goes um
and then she goes well wait a second she
goes my birthstone's not clear I got the
wrong birthstone for the yeah so your
faults are their fault their fault okay
that's my fault well because now you got
a reason to return it well they got to
replace it they're gonna replace the
stone let me ask you a question by the
way actually no no no it wasn't uh it
wasn't on their fault it was it was my
fault but it's all good
um um uh let me ask you a question
though let me ask you a question yeah so
we talked about my watch I bought the uh
the watch the the AP watch remember we I
wore it in here before ah the Audemars
okay okay I bought the one yeah how much
cash good money
the only watch I have it's the only
watch you have and you bought it from
these people too yes great people but
let me ask you the watch would I spend
shout at all they
it it the time and date don't have not
they worked and now they don't can they
consistently have not worked is it a
self-winding watch
which I've self-wound which they've
self-wound they've demagnetized it
doesn't work oh I leave and then it
doesn't work so now what they've done is
they've taken the watch and they've
mailed it back to AP which is going to
take five to six weeks to get back
because there's something wrong with it
because there must be but my question
right but my question should is and I
didn't do this because I'm just never
think of it but just as I have you here
should I have asked for a replacement
watch in the interim or for something
I'm not the guy that usually does that
but if you pay shut up
would you and it to watch I've only had
to watch two months and it's already
messed up what would your course of
action be
um because I assume it's gonna be fair
it's not like a car dealership right so
if it's just it's defective it's
defective what can you do the effective
I think it's effective you get a full
refund it's got to be right that has to
be my question is with the watch of this
caliber when you send it out how do you
know you're not getting back a fake
because they're sending it because the
people I got it from I trust and they
are sending a two actual AP they are an
actual AP Boutique dealership look at
the things on screen nobody sees these
but us okay yes it's uh tell me like
somewhere in the neighborhood which is
four different price points here it's
the middle one that's that's one second
one yes that one now that's not the
watch but that's about what it costs
that's to watch
that's the watch and that's what it
costs pre-owned no no that's oh no that
says pre-owned that's the price oh no no
no so then that no no no so then I'm I'm
a mind course pre-owned that what this
one the first one royal royal oak that's
what I have pre-owned yeah wait wait
wait no I bought it at face valve I
bought it at retail okay new new it as
soon as you leave as soon as uh on the
secondary Market it doubles in value
doubles
why would anyone buy anything on the
secondary Market because people just
want the watch and the thing is you
can't have get the access to these
watches unless you know someone get in
that's why they're very clear if you
resell this watch without them and you
don't go through like if I bought that
watch right I have a great connect now
if I bought that watch and I resold it
Black Market because I'm going to get
twice the value if I just left the store
if I left the store and I paid 10 grand
for it I could go out and get 20 grand
for it immediately but I'm the guy
that's like I want that watch why am I
going to you and not buying it because
you don't have access to the guys to get
in to get it at retail how did you get
access you walk into a store and answer
it no no you can't that's the thing it's
not that kind of store you got to get
buzzed in there's a guy with a machine
gun out the door I swear to God that's
the thing I got in through uh Andrew
Santino gave me a connect who got to
connect from like it's that it's like so
they get into rails exactly so if you
sell the watch behind their back you are
out of that Community you will never get
anything on Facebook I feel like yeah
mission that way exactly they are like
the Amish or the Hasidic Jews which is
more close Okay so that so so that's the
thing it's like I'm in this community so
and I know these people but now you
gotta the date don't work it don't work
so what would you do in my search would
you ask for something what would you do
well what they're telling you is you're
gonna get the watch you ordered in
pristine working condition back in about
five weeks right but now I don't have
have a watch that I paid money for that
like events and stuff so what would you
throw it on a credit card I threw it on
a credit card and then you got the
points for that I got the points oh yeah
just paid it off paid it off my taking
my family to Orlando this week a nice
little vacation which we'll talk about
use the points from that watch by by the
flights okay okay so but but you can't
ask for it you think it's just it's just
part of the game you want to be you want
to buy a watch at that price you ask for
that's the thing what could I ask for
what there's nothing I could even ask
because it's going to come back to you
in working conditions right so you you
haven't you have a you can attach a
monetary value to your inconvenience
right they deal in inconveniences I mean
the guy has a machine gun yeah that's
the thing it's like I can't and what if
the FedEx truck gets like hit by an
asteroid there's got to be I have to
have I think I have I have insurance on
the watch I took out an insurance policy
with a if something happened or a force
damage who yeah I I have in the house
you have it you have to you have to list
that in your house insurance yeah I have
it I have that so if God forbid it got
stolen I I have I have the value of it
okay not the secondary value the initial
value right so yeah but
you can make a case that the secondary
value is the value right they're going
to give you what you initially paid for
like I mean look at this look at this
Royal Oak offshore
1.3 schmillion dollars how did you
choose this brand
which I have the exact one how did you
choose it
uh send Andrew the Great Andrew Santino
who's you know known watch guy no he he
was like you got this is a watch for you
you got to get this watch and I saw it
in person loved it
um
loved it now I have I have one one ex I
would call very expensive watch it's not
that expensive just to me it's expensive
because prior to this my watch as well
between like 50 and 500 right in my
entire life by the way I don't have any
other watch but that watch I'm not a
watch guy I bought it once I like to I
feel I don't know that I'm gonna
continue to do it well that's what I was
gonna ask you because the watch I got
that I think is expensive is
significantly less than that do you have
any hesitation throwing that on about
where you're going with it no because
the reason to be like break yourself
full exactly but the reason why I like
that watch over say like uh flashy Rolex
is because when you see a Rolex it's
very well known it's very known like
gold Rolex that's a lot of money
the average everyday guy doesn't know
that that's a very expensive watch it
could be a watch that you got at the
mall nonetheless though as you know huh
is your guard up like you're not gonna
oh my God my guard's always up when I'm
walking when I'm walking through anyway
I'm always you always ready I'm always
like this shaking I always have this I'm
always I'm always clap like if I walk up
to anybody in the street I'm like that
right yeah so or I'm throwing crane
kicks I'm doing something so
I'm always already throwing them so it's
not like you're in The Stance I ask
anybody who's known seen me in the
streets if you see me if I'm waiting I'm
actively throwing crane kicks just so
you know that you don't want to get
close that's nice especially with my
family's there that I have to a crank is
a is the best kick to do a lot in a row
because you have to reset it yes yes
like I you know also in the Karate Kid
because that's what we all learned which
I've never seen
I swear to God I've never seen the
Karate Kid I've never seen the new one
on YouTube I've never seen it but the
Karate Kid a ridge I just never seen it
nope wow so when did you learn about the
crane kick I because what I did was we
did a uh like a like a spoof on it with
already Lang in like 2012 and one of I
was playing the I was playing The Karate
Kid guy and they had me do a crane kick
question is the cream cake real or did
the Korean kick was made for that scene
in The Karate Kid and then let me give
you another thing after I after we find
this out it's fictionalized version of
the May Toby
Jerry the move was created by Daryl
Vidal for the classical okay oh it's
created okay so can you go back to the
picture of him
now what happens here is guys this
podcast as you know is sponsored by
betterhelp whether you're feeling or
dealing with decisions around your
career relationships or anything else
therapy helps you stay connected to what
you really want while you navigate your
life so you can move forward with the
confidence and excitement trusting
yourself to make decisions that align
with your values is like anything the
more you practice it the easier it gets
now so if you are thinking of starting
therapy why not give better help a try
well it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule so you just go and you fill out
a brief questionnaire and you get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists at any time
with no additional charge let therapy be
your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com hey babe today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
help.com hey babe
let's talk hello fresh number one meal
okay it's America's number one meal kit
with hello fresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients you understand
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep you can skip trips to the
grocery store you count on hellofresh to
make home cooking easy fun affordable
that's why it is America's number one
meal make your home the hangout place to
Summer with crowd-pleasing eats from a
backyard bratwurst bar to Tangy key lime
pie hellofresh Market make summer
entertaining a cinch are you looking to
eat well this summer I know I am
hellofresh menu features calorie smart
and protein smart lunch and dinner
options plus new vegan dinners to choose
from hellofresh makes it easy to reach
your food goals and flavorful recipes
that leave you feeling satisfied uh it's
fun to get in the mail too it comes in a
brown bag I'll open it up everything's
pre-portioned they have a recipe card it
actually makes cooking fun it really
does it's coming from someone who does
not cook here's what you gotta do you
gotta go to hellofresh.com hey babe five
zero and use the code hey babe five zero
for for 50 percent off plus free
shipping that's hellofresh.com hey babe
five zero use the code hey babe five
zero for five zero percent off plus free
shipping hellofresh America's number one
meal kit here's what I'm saying you here
now this is the movie so in the movie
Daniel Russo is a kid from New Jersey
he's from Jersey yeah he's like from
Secaucus because I knew that from the
from the spoof and they relocate to like
like uh Northern California or something
like that and then he goes into this
high school and
he rubs elbows the wrong way with Johnny
who is basically uh the the leader of
this group of friends that all take
karate right he ends up of having a
relations uh he he flirts with Johnny's
girlfriend who's Elizabeth's shoe right
nobody blames him who and who is who is
has no uh correlation or no direct
lineage
right and uh and then so they beat the
piss out of him and then he finds Mr
Miyagi and Mr yagi takes him under his
wing he teaches him and they end up uh
culminating in this big tournament that
comes through okay and then he's making
his way through tournament and it's no
no mercy really with this right with his
other with this other Dojo there's no
mercy right so they they did underhanded
anything that it takes to win yeah right
and now this is the final literal final
bout of the final scene of the
tournament of the movie right you're the
guy in the left not you but let's say
you're the guy left and this is exactly
a freeze frame how do you not know that
something's coming your way
you're telling me yeah even if you
didn't know karate your antenna doesn't
come up that if I walk forward
something's about to happen yeah
does he nail people with us in the movie
no he only does it this time so also
it's like well what is this name he
wasn't doing it you know so he floors
this guy with this he goes
and then he runs and he kicks him in the
face and he pulls down he runs right
into his foot which but he's literally
cocked waiting to do it yeah it does
yeah I I don't um he you look up and you
you bump it to someone on the street
you're like bro watch it and you turn
around and the guy is like with this
looking at you
do you think this person's crazy this
person
I don't understand this and so I'm gonna
back away from this waiting for you
right here no idea yeah I know it's
waiting for you no I have no idea well
he ran right into that thing right into
it yeah but but you see what I mean
though if you kept doing that in
succession it'd be really funny because
you have to keep getting into that first
position like yeah by the way recently
your dad bothering Ralph Macchio at the
Mets game was my favorite thing Ralph
Martin we brought my dad to the Mets
game and my dad we were in uh an area
where Ralph Macchio was there and my dad
started talking to Ralph Macchio and
wouldn't leave Ralph Macho alone right
is that what what did
yeah two Ralph Macchio was rooting for
the Mets but he thought they were on the
same side it was really uncomfortable I
loved it yeah it was great it was it
like a box or something yeah and
eventually Ralph moved away it was you
Tampa Tony is the man Tampa Tony so
funny wow yeah you know when I saw a
Karate Kid I saw at the Highland twin
okay and I came still there long gone
long it was a two it was a two memory
screen thing back in like the late 80s
and I saw it with my dad and I came out
and it was like when you saw Rocky you
came out and you were like I probably
know karate now right and I remember
walking to the car and we were walking
along the storefronts and then there was
a section of brick wall and I threw a
crane kick at the brick wall just like
just fully spontaneous yeah I just was
like that wasn't me and my dad like that
was amazing I just threw crane kick
against the wall I kicked it and I
literally broke my goddamn toe no like
actual toe break for real no but it it
just just just just feel like it like it
felt broken like you were you were
screaming you were like I thought I was
gonna like kick it and I didn't and I
kicked it straight down and I literally
was like like literally basically crying
right right after I walked out of Karate
Kid right yeah I couldn't kicked the
brick wall yeah yeah yeah people that do
that are it it because it all happens
like I saw fast and the furious with my
friends when we were 16 17 years old and
my friend made believe he was driving
like Tokyo Drift But we were in like a
1991 Toyota Corolla like so it's like
not on the Whitestone expressway yeah so
it's like not doing anything no people
definitely get hurt I bet you that
happens more than we think people get so
psyched up with movies that they get
hurt immediately the most dangerous time
during a movie is the hour when it's
over yeah because somebody's gonna act
like that the last time it happened to
me I walked out of a rec room for a
dream in the parking lot I started
each other's on the ferry
[Laughter]
you should always put the name of a
sponsor over any type of curse we should
do that pick a sponsor seriously put
Mark that I'm being serious pick a
different spot
that's so funny to do that that's so
funny like that mother hellofresh yeah
yeah yeah
um um yeah yeah so do you remember when
I was younger the movies were much more
communal in a way that people like I saw
Rocky
three okay in the lane theater on noodle
Lane with my dad okay and which was a
comedy club at one point Uncle Vinnie's
Comedy Club it then became later on
became the lane theater oh is that right
yeah and now it's not now it's now I
think it's a church like a Jehovah's
Witness church not a Jehovah's Witness
say uh you know Jesus Christ proper huge
theater yeah it became Uncle Vinnie's
Staten Island Comedy Club Oh I thought
it was okay I'm thinking of Grandpa's
that was on just up a block of you it
was you know Grandpa from the monsters
yeah he had a comedy club in San Antonio
called Grandpa's Comedy Club what his
monster head was on the door
what yeah I saw a dice there on new door
plane yeah no on uh the service road on
the service road where the train is to
stand on train just just just right up I
mean literally up the block from Uncle
Vinnie where when did when was Grandpa's
there it was like uh 80s 90s can you
Google Grandpa's Comedy Club Staten
Island that's fascinating yeah and I
don't know why that man had a comedy
club and Dice Clay performed there after
he was already humongous yeah he was big
it was a big thing I think when did it
close would you say
oh my God I maybe he was a comic he must
have been a comic Al Lewis
right Al Lewis yeah Grandpa it closed
what in the 90s you think or even before
well maybe I didn't I I was there
multiple no you know what it was because
I remember when I went there I was
underage because they let you go
underage and we would go with like
friends and they would drink virgin
drinks or whatever like they would drink
like a whipped cream drink or whatever
dice was there
I didn't see I'm thinking of another
time I saw a dice but dice did play
there and everybody like it was it was
nuts he was big because I remember it
was a huge thing it was like in the
paper and everybody was like everybody
like crowded around outside and stuff
right right wow that's yeah comedy
Staten Island is uh I have an
announcement
there's a possibility
there's a possibility I might be moving
off Staten Island you are yo-yo yo yo yo
you're walking the dog right now I can't
even keep up let's I just want to talk
to you about
owning a house versus owning an
apartment or living in a house first
living in an apartment I am realizing
although I love the island days tatan I
love all the culture I love the people
all those stereotypes you hear I don't
see it I don't feel it even when I do
see them feel it I love it anyway
because I'm like this is culture I love
these people it's not has nothing to do
with that it's that if you had if you
had me running trying to maintain a
house anywhere any other I it's very
it's becoming very difficult for me uh
the not being able to walk anywhere is
becoming very difficult running a house
is not self-sustaining once you get the
Kinks worked out it is but you have to
pay people to do that and no no no even
if you don't pay able to do it Sal I'm
telling you and and it may be because
I'm a very novice homeowner it something
is needs to be maintained or breaks or
fixed or up kept every week something
something something something you have
to do something the gutters the boiler
the pool the backyard the Landscaping
the inside house something breaks you're
on the line to fix it you have to and I
don't know how to do that I have to call
a guy to do it now I said let me get
motivated let me learn how to do it let
me YouTube things all that stuff I've
been doing it it's not sitting right
with me I'm like now Jasmine is as handy
Jasmine's handier than our dads like
Jasmine literally can build a house does
she feel the same way that you do about
yes she does she's like I don't she's
like I feel like like for example today
she's like I'm you know we're here doing
the show I'm like what are you gonna do
and she goes it gets like you know and
it's not her fault it's like I get it
she's like well I have to do all the
kids laundry I have to clean this whole
house I have to uh clean the pool I she
has all these chores to do because the
house consumes you it consumes
everything about you where if we lived
in an apartment yes it'd be the kids
would lose the pool and the yard but we
figured you know we could go to a pool
or a yard or we could get them out into
the park whatever you don't have to
maintain as much and then when something
breaks it's really not your
responsibility it's the super honestly
so you had these thoughts couple of
months ago yes and then you flipped
flipped right back and then you
flipped because I changed from mozambic
to munjaro okay
no I understand no so so so now you're
napping again I'm flipping again let's
flip this house what happened when you
flipped when you felt that way and
flipped back what happened to those
feelings so those feelings what happened
was when I flipped back because really
let's be honest you're only going to be
it's whatever the woman wants I don't
care how much we say you know uh it's a
man's world it's it's whatever the woman
wants Brown sing that song right yeah
well shout out James Brown that's a
woman that I want the the the
it's whatever she wants and now my woman
has said you know what I I I'm getting a
little sick of I feel like I'm now
becoming a Suburban housewife I'm
becoming now a person who my whole life
is for this house okay she's like I
don't like it I don't feel like I'm out
in the community at all because don't
forget when we take the kids to school
you guys are big in the community we're
big Community people we're I want to be
a pillar I'd like to be a pillar
and and and so you're not going to be
able to be a pillar when you're standing
when you're kind of on a hill by
yourself right now I'm in a Hiller and
I'm a Healer and I want to be a pillar
you do you you want to like get your you
want to roll up your sleeves and be a
pillar of your community for my example
the perfect day would be a day like if
we were living somewhere else take the
kids to school walk them already I want
to be by 9am I want to have casually my
5 000 steps cash I'm just walking around
yeah I love that that's you we had that
in Bay Ridge we would cat I mean 10 000
steps by lunchtime right no problem so
steps is where your steps is what I'm
thinking about I'm thinking about I have
and we've been looking and I have a
pedometer on me at all times I was
thinking about how many steps would I
get in and out of this house but I a
perfect day because what happens is you
know how it goes yeah because I gotta
drive sit in traffic on Staten Island to
take to get the kids to school I got my
pedometer I'll let you know how much I
walked along I gotta get you know the
kids get on the bus school bus which is
fine which is fine let them get on the
school bus whatever but they you know
but then the baby we got to take her to
daycare 20 minutes come back 20 minutes
can't really go we can't really leave
Staten Island because the kids are going
to be home by certain time so so if
we're going to leave Staten Island
during the week you gotta leave you got
to get everything you got to get done
within the if you got to come to the
city to do anything you got everything
you got to get done between the hours of
11 to 1 because it's going to take an
hour and a half to get back it takes an
hour and a half to get into the city
because you know the traffic yeah so we
kind of feel like if we were more
centrally located we could have we feel
like our friends who have children our
age that live in other parts of of uh
not on sun Island are living their life
doing everything and we're just getting
send videos of what we're missing
because we have the beautiful house so
much more beautiful house than they do
but they're living a more quality life
and we're I'm not now I'm not equating
money anymore to square footage I'm
equating it more to community and I feel
like on Center it's beautiful people but
I I for us we want to be in the thick of
it I understand you know I'm going
through this 100 identical thing right
same exact conversation but you're born
and raised on Staten Island and there my
friend lies the difference but that's
what I think there is no difference
because I have no family on Staten
Island anymore there's nothing keeping
me there what about your mama my mama
gone mama don't live outside in New
Jersey now okay I know so um so there's
no one keeping me there per se okay uh
my lady's family is there and some of
her friends are still there so that's
that's fine because I I interact with
both of those people your lady is also
open to the idea of leaving Staten
Island well we were because we're
looking at homes
yes and we were about to like really
pull a trigger there and then there was
some hesitation with some things and so
we got a second to think and we had the
same debate like do we want to access an
energy and constant like you know like
out the door and you're right in the
thick of It kind of thing and if you do
you're gonna have to sacrifice a yard
possibly a pool a basement you know
multiple bedrooms for people to come
visit you this so we had to try and
weigh because I was coming off the
pandemic and I always thought I was
moving to the to the city of Brooklyn to
maybe like a townhouse or an apartment
you thought for sure after the pandemic
was over you're off the island I was
like I'm gonna move to the the West
Village or like Brooklyn 100 that's what
I thought yeah they were or buy or buy a
house or build house whatever but we but
then the pandemic hit and I was like no
no we want a yard we won't be able to
like you know we want to be able to have
all those amenities at home and not have
to go anywhere but that was I was PTSD
from the Pandy sure but uh and then so
now we were heading hurricane Pandy yeah
and then and then we went to uh we went
and looked at all these apartments right
in the the city and nothing nothing you
didn't you didn't like any of them what
was it what was turning you away from
that I took the budget that I was going
to use on a home and I applied the
budget in Manhattan and Brooklyn and
yeah yeah it's it's yes you got to have
it's tough because you want everything
you want you need like a 10 million
place a square footage and it's like all
right yes can I walk out of my house and
be right at the cellar can I walk out of
my house and be right to all these
restaurants and shops and things like
that in Brooklyn and good energy yes
then I go back into my house and do I
feel like okay yes I understand that I
understand the castle but my my
Counterpoint is is is from living it
right now is I think that yeah we're
going to talk about threads in a second
faster social media platform ever to
surpass 100 million users it's it's like
Facebook's answer to Twitter meta's
answer to Twitter threads okay so so
um um yeah I have one I have one I'm on
there at 30 Roosevelt so uh no but I
told my guy guy runs on social media to
tweet out I'm Freddie Roosevelt I don't
know if he did okay
um uh that might be the name though
maybe we should I should actually
probably be the name Freddie Roosevelt
yeah I'm gonna be thread Durst you're
going to be thread all right hold on let
me just yeah I should tell him like make
sure uh he's just like you just log on
and make one yeah so you really want
another one yeah we uh have a hey babe
and taste buds thread we do it's it's um
you just log into Instagram press two
buttons and you have a thread wait let
me just hold up can we pause this one
the thing now I'm seeing like at nine
two one zero five let me see if the
food's here hold on they give you like a
social security number for their thing
their physical fight with a fight of
platforms so this is Mark Zuckerberg
being petty and launching his own
Twitter as a food too
Elon Musk so is the is I don't know if
you've seen what Elon must have been
doing on Twitter to Mark Zuckerberg no
it's insane I I haven't and he
well today he wants an actual measuring
contest and he's down to be measured
if Zuckerberg will be measured well I
mean that's so silly like any
professional any professional person he
just looks ridiculous like Mark
Zuckerberg like I wouldn't even like
it's
it's but why though what's going on
between them why I think it's just a
battle of the bigger oh Zuckerberg and
musk they're fighting Zuckerberg is a
jiu jitsu expert though so you don't
want to really mess with Zuckerberg I
think he might beat up musk
um I didn't hear any of this so they
have static but can I ask you what is
what is the point of threat is it
exactly with twitters
you post stuff and it's as of right now
it's in it's in its infancy who knows
what it'll become but it's Instagram if
Instagram is Twitter did Elon Musk just
retweet theovan yeah yeah because what's
going on with is there something going
on podcast with Roseanne got ripped and
musk is hosting it on Twitter
got it okay good Theo Von's podcast with
Roseanne got ripped down from YouTube
and that is owned by Facebook
uh no Google so what is
Zuckerberg has nothing to do with this
no no that's it and then he ripped down
why uh Roseanne said something crazy
about the Holocaust as a joke it was a
bit okay but musk now I think with musk
and Twitter you can now put our like you
could put your entire podcast fully
update if you pay them yeah right right
what you can now put your entire podcast
on Twitter you don't have to it used to
be whatever what was it my two three
minute Clips yeah now you can put like
we want to put our entire Hour episode
out on Twitter it's a video we could do
that or your whole special can we
backlog it I don't know if you want to
spam it I don't know I don't know if it
helps you what I think what the debate
is happening now is for the good guys
Twitter's for the bad guys right is that
what the narrative the media is trying
to push okay so you meaning you could
just post an hour-long video is that
what you mean
yeah you can more than that you can post
like you could post like what YouTube
does okay right they have the same
bandwidth there's just no ads right no
ads okay all right I mean so it's
something that we could think about
um but let me ask you this Sal yeah I
got I mean I have like things to do
like who is what is all this well listen
to get away
doesn't everybody have like things to do
yeah right it's just so much of this
nonsense like it's a lot I'm telling you
man I'm not joking dude I want I want to
be Amish maybe why like I I am busy from
the time I wake up to the time I go to
bed I got a real life [__] going yeah
dude how about this I had enough of this
like I need it I think that and I think
that a lot of people now
um I think like you babe I got a brand
new hour of stand-up material I'm
filming a special for it in December so
come see it live before then we got
Atlantic City New Jersey The Borgata
August 18th 19th September 5th and 6th
Irvine California September 8th Portland
September 9th Seattle and then of course
September 22nd and 23rd we have Radio
City Music Hall in New York City and the
theater at MSG
um and then September 30th is Las Vegas
Nevada and then all my October November
December dates are chrisdcomedy.com get
tikiwickies what's up guys you got one
last weekend to see the practical jokers
first leg of the tour uh July next week
July 27 28 29 we're in Nashville
Indianapolis and St Louis
impracticaljokerslive.com the second leg
of the tour is not happening until
January or so in 2024. in January
speaking of January 2024 is the
Impractical Jokers cruise that we are
throwing with Eric Andre the Cruz is
going to be insane it's the fifth one if
you've been on it I know I'll see you if
you've never been on it you gotta come
it's a Once in a Lifetime party you can
get uh signed up at get shipfaced
cruise.com and then your boy right now
is filming a special in December in
Chicago and my tour kicks off in two
weeks uh and I'm gonna be all over town
go to savocano comedy.com for tickets
we're starting off which is a Hartford
uh Syracuse and Albany funny bones and
then we are moving along to Bowling
Green and uh Illinois and
um so on and so forth just check it out
it's all out now and I don't even know I
think there was a pre-sale I don't have
all the information but if you just go
to salvocano comedy.com you can locate
everything and then buy some merch I got
merch tastemade's got merch hey baby has
merch I'm done talking
how about this you ready for this I
heard this on the daily uh stoic podcast
and I'm gonna post this question to you
I posted the pimp off air they said he
said that his his Ryan holiday said that
he heard a quote or maybe this is his
own definition I'm not sure but it was
on The Daily stockpod which was a good
one that his definition of success is
autonomy do you are you autonomous in
your life and career if the answer is
yes you're successful if the answer is
no you are not successful despite the
money or fame or whatever you may have
so do you feel autonomous give me an
example of someone who feels completely
autonomous that's why I understand the
measuring State well like Ryan holiday
said on his part that he feels
successful because he's autonomous well
no he's saying that he's always you know
he can he he he now like his best days
in his career are the days when he
doesn't have anything on his schedule he
can go pick up the kids from school he
can get his writing done because he's
not attached anything to the money when
he's got businesses and things meetings
all the eve even he said when he's got
his big speaking engagement which is
where the money comes from he's lost his
autonomy and that is not as successful
for him there's probably a lot more
layers to it that I don't understand
because I'm an idiot and I just listen
to him and he's smart and I'm dumb but
but I feel like there is something to
say about autonomy with I'm bringing
that up to say these guys the Zuckerberg
in the most of the world I don't know
that they're addicted to the apps that
they want you to be addicted to I don't
know that they are they might be but I
don't know I think that they have more
autonomy this kind of autonomy I mean
you can if he wants but like
isn't I mean he's he's him right so his
day is we can't even fathom what his day
is no right so how does he have autonomy
I don't have autonomy then I don't I'm
so Then therefore the stoics definition
would say that there's not or that then
you don't have success if you if you
don't attach it if you got to get money
out of the equation which is tough to do
because we all need money you got to
support yourself and support your
families and yeah but I but I guess it
would be good to have not to I guess I
wish a nice gold have more autonomy yeah
I have six jobs right
right there's no more time yeah because
a lot of people don't know that you're
not only you're doing all this custom
cupcake exactly exactly you have that
and then you have your the gas station
the gas station the custom case that you
actually pump at most people know the
two pods the solo touring the group
touring
the the development the the production
company and then the show and then when
an offshoots of that show they don't
know about the gas station
right and then I saw I'll say it now
because I think you told me you got
fired you're working at the Staples
right there off Highland Boulevard
because you know what it's
Staples
is fun to work at it was yeah I remember
the first time I went into a Staples and
I was going up and down the aisles and I
just love office supplies in abundance
right and I love the variation of office
supplies at my fingertips 100 and I
didn't think that I could purchase
everything and I said how do I how do I
keep around this right and I applied for
a job and they hired me right away how
are you right away they know who you
were yeah
um now going back to the apartment
I'll let me tell you before because I
know we got sidetracked but but let me
just tell you I had I have the house I
have the what I'm finding is is we have
a lot of space we're not utilizing a b
we have a lot of times where the kids
are sitting in their own little spaces
Jazz and I are sitting our own little
spaces and or when we're together we're
together in one room watching movie like
we just saw Guardians of the Galaxy 3
last night loved it good movie
um that's something I'd like to see
seven or eight of I don't need any more
Fast and the Furious as I get it you
drive but the Galaxy there's other guard
there's other galaxies to guard the
juicy extraction too
extraction 2 is sick did you see it yes
it was mind-blowing Chris Helmsworth
gets the [__] beat out of him again yeah
I love extraction too I love any
Christmas did you watch that movie where
you Joe open right yeah it was sick it
was insane how they did that you know a
movie I just saw two on Netflix that's
an old movie came out in 2000 traffic
with Catherine Zeta Jones and Don
Cheadle I've never seen traffic before
yeah like the like Oh you mean the drug
movie drug move yeah I never saw it what
a crash that's what I thought you meant
that was another good movie no is that
what Alicia Silverstone I don't know it
was an ensemble cast James Spader
possibly yeah Alicia is one of those
names where it's hard to know do you
want me to say it as Alicia or Alicia
but that's whatever neither here nor
there
um
we take and then and then we find most
of our day is maintaining the house
right which is whatever and then we kind
of also feel like we have all this space
that we're not necessarily using and
what happens is we have the pool we have
the yard we brought the amenities to our
house but our children are not
socializing as much with other children
as we want them to because we have no no
driver motivation to take them to the
park when we have it all right there so
we living in it now it doesn't matter if
the house is on Staten Island
Westchester whatever the only way that
it would make a difference if if that
house was within walking distance to a
park in the community you might feel a
bit different but it's not and that's
why and that see are you considering a
move to a home that checks those boxes
or right back to urban life we want to
go to we want to try to find the middle
ground and try to get a urban Suburban
Rural right we're in Suburban we're in
Suburban that's middle so we would want
so we would want we would want an urban
you want like a house on on like on like
uh Avenue of the Americas exactly we
want an urban we want an urban
neighborhood with a Suburban feel and we
think we found it Brooklyn oh you've
already started looking well the problem
is the problem is we came from that it
came from Bay Ridge yes so that's kind
of and so we think we found like a nice
apartment but again it because the thing
we have to get past is the children
right is do they they don't want to go
right but but they didn't want to go
from Bay Ridge to Staten Island so we're
at that point where it's like we're
still making decisions for them and
we're starting trying to think like are
we taking the kids out of a really good
environment to do what we want to do or
is this better for them it's because
there's no gun to our head to move or
not move they love it they have their
lot you know they've only been there for
a year though we've only been there over
18 months yeah but it's still at the
point where you know when you talk to
the elders they're like you should but
they're still young enough where it's
like all it takes is for your kids to
like they're going to be upset but then
it's like my 12 year old stepson he
meets one girl my middle daughter meets
one friend the baby is two so she's you
know whatever she does she's [__]
her pants she's literally [__] and
pissing people about this I've talked to
them I've talked to Elders I've talked
to my elders yeah and I even even
brought in some Native American
ancestors that I don't even know that I
I I did I had to make some cameos for me
I know what goofing around like a couple
of a couple of silly gooses but uh what
you're saying though is is genuinely a
very tough situation to be in to know if
you're going to make the right decision
for the children your lives and for the
children because here's the thing too
you want to be by support systems right
so my support that's the thing we love
Staten Island but we if I leave there
I'm I remove myself from all support my
father and and who used to live there
now lives in Florida it's as far away in
New York City as you can be from where
my mother lives like it is it is the
opposite side of the five boroughs and
Jasmine's mother kind of she will come
anywhere so so so we're like where what
support system are we living near on the
island right now we're literally on an
island sometimes we feel that way
because we didn't grow up there and a
lot of our friends who who met through
are all beautiful people we have not met
one bad person yet they're all beautiful
people a lot of their they are from
Staten Island and they're all their
friend groups went to Staten Island and
then they fall out where we are just
kind of like we're not we're not you
know we have you guys as friends of
course but but you know how it is busy
schedules whatever so we're like what
what are we Rosa was thinking about
moving there maybe that'll change your
mind so then I'm gonna then I'm gonna
actually put the house for sale today
uh yeah I mean yeah you know it's about
it's an interesting thing you have to
just cut this Ties on this in your brain
but like for me I'd be like I just lived
through construction yes that's the
thing I I sacrificed but you can't yeah
that's that I I didn't live through
because I lived in my basement how you
feel today but yes and and end and the
the the the real estate agent who we
know who's a personal friend was like
look because I'm even the thought even
the thought of a move is like
mind-numbing how much stress that is and
whatever and they were like listen just
for that just for that if you wanna you
know have enough you know do as much of
it as you can but if you have the means
to pay a little bit extra well they'll
pack things up for you then just do that
and go and just have them set it up in
the new place go don't even be there
don't try trying to really now I know
not everyone can do that I don't even
know if I could afford this whole full
White Glove service thing that that but
but but it's in option you don't you
started batting around locations you
went and looked we went and looked
because we went looked because we were
like you know what let's just see let's
see how we feel and here's the
interesting thing here's the interesting
thing that sometimes you just have to do
it to see
we there was one apartment that we
really liked but there's issues with it
in the sense of you know you have to
need a bit of renovation it's also like
in a co-op board so you have to like do
some things where it's like it's not as
easy and when the architect because we
just had a friend who's an architect
when the architect
came and kind of was saying he's not
sure if this could happen for this place
it was interesting to talk to Jasmine
about that she was like I started to
feel very upset that it wasn't maybe
going to work with that place so she was
like that's telling me that like we
wanted to be here and then when we went
back to Staten Island we still come in
our house and like like yesterday we
were watching the movie we're like we
love like look at how beautiful our
house is look at how great this is yeah
but then when we woke up this morning we
were like oh [__] yeah the movie's over
we're out of that room now we're back to
the house owns us again yeah so I I got
I got I got tired of living in buildings
though too like the co-ops are such
[__] this is bored and everyone
knows everyone's business you got to go
through them for everything and you
gotta like there's no just walking right
into your house you're parking a parking
lot or whatever on the street and then
you got to take all your packages up and
down right they just think there are
pros and cons to both that that gets
annoying in my head I'm like I just
would like to pull into privacy and
serenity right so those were my two
Paramount things that I was thinking
right so obviously I have that with I
mean to be able to pull up literally to
my front door in Staten Island it's
tough this this new place that you know
you yeah it's you're like you said it's
like a garage and it's it's a whole
different life yeah and I remember when
I was living in my apartment even I
would get angry like I gotta wait for
the [__] elevator again yeah you know
like you start to get frustrated but but
you start to then also feel like what's
that and I like there's sometimes where
I'm like man I gotta sit and sometimes I
feel like wherever I go I gotta leave
the island to get there normally you
know so that there's here's the thing I
probably am much more used to that than
you because she was born and raised I've
been doing it my whole life I've it's
it's just like I know it's just the
necessity right what I have to do right
so yeah well what can you do who knows
what I'll do I'll tell you what's good
news is I'm not swimming in the beaches
because if you swim on the beaches you
will get eaten by a shark if you live in
the New York area it's just what it is
babe everybody's getting bit by sharks
Long Island shark attacks on record
setting Pace after five swimmers bits so
far this summer I am going there I was
in Long Island uh last month for a week
I'm going there in a few days for a week
and I'm in there in August for one week
the place I'm going next week just a
shark just bit somebody will you go in
the Civic place will you go in the ocean
water I I kind of won't now I don't
think like I'm what am I why would I why
why wouldn't why the sharks eating
everybody now are there fasting Windows
different I I I don't know why they're
eating everybody there the sharks are
eating everybody stay off the Sharks by
the way the water is getting warmer
maybe by the way can we watch movie
trailers on here we can't pimp
um I don't know the movie trailer for
the new movie Napoleon the historical
movie Napoleon with Joaquin Phoenix
Place Napoleon is the best movie trailer
I've ever seen in my entire life and I'd
like to watch it with y'all okay
can we do it now well we don't want to
we don't want the whole thing to get
ripped down because of this that's the
thing okay so maybe we'll watch it on
fair but this this I mean it's it's
it's unbelie I've been waiting for them
to make a movie about Napoleon I've been
literally waiting because this story is
Napoleon yeah
wow France 1793. this movie is sick the
storming of the Bastille this has Oscar
written all over it right
is it Apple when does it come out pimp
I love it why why is the eggplant
Napoleon called that what do you mean
the eggplant Napoleon what's an eggplant
Napoleon it's a eggplant stack it's like
eggplant fresh mozzarella beef steak
tomato eggplant freshmans at all why is
Napoleon a little basil little sauce I
think maybe because is it like um
eggplant Napoleon
um
maybe because
um maybe it has nothing to do with that
Napoleon because it maybe it's from
napolitan Italy
eggplant Napoleon name is not really why
maybe why is it called
what do you know about Napoleon
you would be surprised at how little I
know about how much right
can I ask you some questions some
history questions that I was going to
ask people on the street babe I am let's
see how many we can get right history
right is my number one worst
education this only second to Geography
okay this is I mean I'm sorry no it's
geography's second but let's I'm good at
math
I'm good at like science let's see how
many get right this is the thing I want
to go around and start filming you know
I have a show Chris stories where I talk
about I want to go on the street and ask
christery's questions I I I Revel at
your historical knowledge but your
ability to to store your historical
knowledge well the reason that I am not
good at history is math is one that you
learn the technique you apply the
technique history is you got to remember
all this stuff and I honestly I my whole
life I've had severe ADHD and I cannot
retain that it's what you're passionate
about for me I think about like we're
all connected even through our past so
for me it's amazing to look at Napoleon
in 1793 and be like what would what was
life like then were people having the
same problems where people doing their
versions of completely fascinating where
they think about an apartment first
house were they the same issues and I
think the answer is yes yes so
let me um so here's a history question
uh quiz uh christory quiz
sorry if easy how many states are in the
U.S 50. good
who shot and killed Abraham Lincoln John
Wilkes Booth see you're already a lot of
people that's those are those are are
You Smarter Than A Fifth Grader who
fought in the Civil War
what do you mean who who what the North
and South the North and South a lot of
people don't know that what city was the
first capital of the United States
uh was it um
what city was the very first capital
I feel like I should know that it was it
they came over to Jamestown right right
and then maybe it was then the East
Coast
I don't think it was Albany though
what's your guess maybe it's uh
what's the capital of Massachusetts
Boston is it New York City it was the
first capital of the United States it
was it was oh was it New York City was
the first capital of the United States
yes it's not even a capital now
but it was the first it was the capital
what was the name of the ship that first
brought the pilgrims to the United
States
well Santa Maria the Mayflower oh oh
sure sure
what year was same-sex marriage
legalized in New York City uh
2011. you're a homophone okay um
what was the name of New York City
before it was called New York City
I feel like I should oh five times five
towns or something like that New
Amsterdam
before New York yeah New Amsterdam yep
so but you actually know dude you know a
lot of the easy ones and I got the
semi-easy ones wrong because I didn't
pay attention you knew you knew what did
I know I didn't really who was credited
as the first American to walk on the
moon
uh it's uh uh uh I know but Buzz
Lightyear no I know no I know I know who
it is I know who it is but you don't but
if we're playing the game you're not
because I'm gonna give people there's no
choice I'd whip it out quick but that's
the thing because I'm gonna give people
money it's not Buzz Ultra Neil Armstrong
Neil Armstrong I knew that
for what New York City Park has a mini
version of Francis Arc de Triumph
what New York I gotta go with Central
Park Washington Square Park okay so you
don't know a lot of these Oh Oh you mean
uh you mean the yeah oh yeah yeah the
arch yeah say an arch yeah I said the
Arctic Triumph oh Arc the Triumph that
was an easy one okay like Marble Arch in
London yeah yeah what what was Martin
Luther King Jr's original name
um multiple choice
Martin Luther King Jr
Michael
yeah okay yeah okay all right so you
would have uh yeah you well the way that
I'm gonna do it is if you ask it what
would my uh Martin Luther King Jr's
friends call him
June bug really yeah there you go look
it up
um okay so you did good you didn't do
well at all I blanked on Neil Armstrong
if you said Buzz Lightyear which is
which that would be that would be
the answer that would make the clip yeah
yeah yeah no no no officers who's Neil
who's the guy who lost the testicle and
cheated
lanterns are okay all right there you go
all right okay all right all right so I
you know where did we land here I don't
know you may or may not be moving I may
not know nothing about history right uh
don't walk into a crane kick don't walk
into a crazy see someone do this yeah
take pause take pause and from previous
episodes wisdom if you want to save the
lives of your family and your children
then you should go Amish go Amish which
I I really am thinking about doing I'm
not gonna you know yeah I know we have
to go I know we have to go and I'll just
part with this I have been reflecting
for real seriously and I have been
thinking about what you said already
whereas I I'm flirting with the idea
of fully
really for real I I had a serious
conversation about this and I don't know
how much I could do it but I'm flirting
about the with the idea of
this has been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey
[Music]